And we're live.
What's that brick
happy memorial day.
Happy Memorial Day.
A perfect day to have you want to
talk about your project because this,
um,
it's called a fighting season.
It's available right now on iTunes.
And for folks who,
uh,
are not,
aware of Rick Schroeder,
first of all,
how dare you and a actor,
I'm now director,
producer,
you're doing a lot of different things
and we've been friends for what,
10 years now?
10 years.
Yeah.
Long time girls introduced
this thankfully.
Yeah.
So you are documentary
series is pretty intense man.
And you showed me a bunch of it last
time I was over your house and I was the,
first of all I was really impressed.
But one of the things I was
really impressed with was
your commitment to doing
this.
I mean you spent a lot of time in,
in Afghanistan and uh,
like embedded.
You were with the soldiers in firefights.
I mean you were there pretty
much every step of the way.
Yeah.
I was there 110 days
from March until July,
2014 and I needed to be there because
I needed to be there that long because
just to build trust with the,
the soldiers and the units that I would
embed with took sometimes weeks alone
just to,
because everybody looked at me like,
what's this journalists doing here?
A lot of the guys were 20,
22,
25 in these platoons.
No,
had no idea of my past.
They thought I was just a journalist
and camera guy that was there to tell a
story that was probably negative.
So just took time to build
a relationship with them,
um,
before I got into their worlds.
And,
but you know,
it's funny the,
you know,
when,
when you do go out and got combat patrol
and you do have contact with an enemy,
then like all of a sudden
you know that you're with,
you're one of them.
So it like totally changes the dynamic,
but it has to be some big event has to
happen typically for them to accept you.
Wow.
That's,
that's pretty intense man.
So what was the motivation to do this?
And like,
when did you decide,
how long did it take to plan this out?
Like,
yeah,
so the motivation is probably,
you know,
I was always curious about what war was,
war is just one of those things
that it has affected mankind and,
and,
and change the course of history
since the beginning of time.
Right.
The act of war.
And so,
you know,
I was always curious about what war was.
And I,
in my mind,
I always thought,
wow,
I have to experience what it is or else
I don't have like a whole picture of
what it means to be,
you know,
in this state of,
this condition has man.
So I was always looking for an opportunity
where I could sort of experienced it.
Um,
but you know,
I didn't come along for a long,
long time,
but after nine 11,
you know,
I've been sitting there watching,
US fight in the war on
terror for 13 or 14 years.
My living room,
like there were most of us.
And you know,
I,
I had an opportunity because I knew
a three star general named Lieutenant
General Anderson at the Fort Bragg,
North Carolina who was
deploying to Afghanistan in
the spring of 2014 so I asked
Joe,
I said,
can I go with you guys?
And he's like,
why do you want to go?
And I'm like,
well Joe,
I think it's important to document,
you know,
what we've accomplished or failed to
accomplish in that country for the last 13
years.
We've spent a lot of money there,
we've lost a lot of people there,
we've had a lot of handicapped
and amputees come from that war.
And I think it's important to
show what ending a war looks like,
how hard it is,
how complicated is,
how ugly it is.
And so he agreed and he said,
okay,
I'll make it happen.
Now this was when you had already
started doing that show for the army.
You had done this show.
What was the show called?
The,
the project that I started working for,
what's called starting strong,
started working for the army for,
that's a branded content shell.
It's like long form kind of,
um,
a infomercial in a sense,
ultimately for the starting
strong for the military.
I mean,
that's a 30 minute,
it's not truly a reality show,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's branded content.
It's,
it's messaging that they want in there
that I helped produce and I have a
government contract and
I produced that for them.
So in that sense,
one of the conversations
that we had about that,
they,
they're fairly restrictive about what
you ere and what you don't air and you
didn't have a lot of
creative freedom with that.
That's right.
I mean,
they,
it's a long form commercial
jail starting strong,
but it's,
it's well done and it's real.
There's nothing in it that's not,
not truthful,
but it's definitely controlled by the
army and the messaging that they want to
put into it.
So it's not necessarily balanced.
Like the negative aspects
are not really shown.
You're just kind of showing
the things that they want.
Yeah.
And ultimately they have
the final edit there,
the final judge and jury on
those decisions when you have,
you know,
a creative,
uh,
difference.
So that really kind of opened your eyes
to this possible or open your mind to
this possibility of doing this
nonrestrictive embedded reality.
I mean this is a real,
a real documentary that,
yeah,
this is the real deal.
I mean this is,
this is John Paul Dejoria,
the guy who owns patroned Tequila in me,
uh,
each kicking in a chunk
of money and you know,
putting together a film crew.
And I scrambled after I talked to Joe
Anderson and Fort Bragg in February,
I was in Afghanistan by February,
by March and I brought
three camera guys with me.
I brought,
I hired a local there and
the only limitation the
army put on me was they said
we are going to have to review for
operational security and any things that
could endanger our soldiers
or give away capabilities,
tactics,
techniques and procedures of certain
weapon systems or things that we employ to
defeat the enemy.
Which,
which is pretty interesting stuff.
And I can talk about
a little bit with you,
some of those tools we have.
Like what were the things that
you were not allowed to put in?
So like when we were on the,
let's say I'm a drone,
we were,
when we were trying to do dynamic or,
or um,
kinetic strikes with drones on bad guys,
we were following,
um,
known terrorists that had pictures and
names and we were following them from the
air.
Um,
and looking for opportunities to shoot
hellfire missile and eliminate them.
Um,
there's certain information that's on
the drone feeds the monitor feeds that
gives away sort of
capabilities of the drone.
I see.
And so we had to blur that.
Um,
there was certain weapons systems which
are just brand new that you couldn't
even talk about and people will know
that they're not released to the public.
Yeah,
that's always tripped me out.
Like things like the area
51 stuff and the groom,
Lake weather test,
all this crazy technology out there and
people don't even know about it until
it's too late.
It's one of the things,
not,
not too late necessarily,
but I mean until it's already employed.
One of the things,
um,
that they attribute to a
lot of the UFO sightings.
It was like stealth bombers and the
B 52 and [inaudible] 51 and all these
different technologies they had created
out there in the [inaudible] desert and
people had no idea they even existed
until they started using them.
You know,
the technology that I saw an experience
with the army and the way that they can,
you know,
fight and conduct war and gather
intelligence and stuff was,
it was phenomenal.
Absolutely phenomenal.
Um,
at that,
that being said,
there's only so much you can
do to overcome an adversary
that's a suicide bomber
that's going to,
you know,
load the car with explosives
and drive it into your,
you know,
check point,
um,
or walk up to you and detonate.
There's only so much you
can do with technology.
Um,
and it's,
there's just certain things it's
hard to mitigate against and that,
that's fanatics.
Yeah.
And this war in particular and a,
the first desert storm war,
it was really the first time that they
had experienced that as the United States
military and experienced
that from the enemy,
right.
Except the Japanese suicide bombers.
But the kamikaze is,
it was sort of a different story.
Yeah.
I mean that's the only time I can
really remember is the weapon of choice
becoming,
um,
a human,
you know,
his,
um,
World War II with the kamikazes and then,
you know,
you started hearing about it in Iraq,
um,
and that really wasn't
employed and Afghanistan for
many years early in the war.
And then they decided to
change tactics and bring,
bring that to the battlefield.
But you know,
the really disgusting thing with,
with some of that is,
you know,
they use kids a lot for suicide bombers.
Um,
you know,
kids that are handicapped,
kids that have mental problems,
down syndrome or handicaps in some way,
they'll actually,
you know,
radicalize the kids in Pakistan
madrassas or schools teach them that,
you know,
it's,
um,
it's the highest degree of glory to
die in the act of Jihad because without
jihad actually you can't
actually get the 72 versions.
So the kids are actually trained to
thank the Americans kind of in a way,
or thank the out of the infidels
because without the infidels to kill,
you can't get the highest degree of,
of a celestial glory.
That term,
72 virgins.
Apparently.
I looked it up.
What a lot of people think that
it's actually like the number 72,
but it's like a shit load.
It's like saying a shit load,
you know,
like you how it's more than 72.
Well,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
it's a term like,
you know,
like it's not a,
it's not an exact term.
I don't know what the a,
the definition that would be,
but you know,
um,
you know,
people say that,
uh,
it's a cajillion
exaggeration.
It was the original,
I mean it's not,
it's not really defined.
It's just a large number of versions that
apparently is what they mean by saying
72.
Cause I always thought
like that's so specific.
What does that mean?
Yeah.
I mean it's a cultural thing obviously,
but yeah.
Um,
so this is really a crazy undertaking.
I mean I really,
I mean you threw your
whole life into this,
you separate yourself from
your family for many months,
a hundred plus days,
and then,
uh,
went over there.
And was there any,
was there any point in time in the,
in the process of this before you
launched where you had second thoughts?
We did,
you know that you were going to commit
yourself to such a long extended stay.
So I did have second thoughts,
um,
before I went,
you know,
especially cause like
three days before I left,
Andrea and my wife said,
don't go.
If you love me,
don't go,
whoa.
And so if you love the kids don't go.
I got that.
And so I had to deal with
that like three days before.
And that was pretty tough.
Um,
because I do love my
wife and do love my kids,
but I went.
So,
um,
but,
but yeah,
I mean it was definitely a hard,
a hard thing to,
um,
to come to terms with tea,
to come to grips with.
Um,
you know,
my camera,
one of my camera guys backed
out the day of the trip.
Um,
and I went out there at one time before
my team actually and just to scout and
look for different embeds in different
characters and stuff that I could follow.
Different soldiers,
different units,
different missions.
And we follow everything in this just,
you know,
from three star general who was the
commander of the battlefield of in all of
Afghanistan to,
you know,
um,
Colonel John Graham,
which is a,
a great embed where he advises
the chief of police and cool,
which is 6 million people,
cops with RPGs,
13,000 man pill,
paramilitary police force in Kabul,
heroin industry,
thriving black market for
weapons thriving and are in bed,
was with criminal Graham embedded
with the chief of police for cobble,
um,
you know,
trying to secure the city
and build the ring of steel.
They called it,
which was like 50 something checkpoints
to try to keep suicide bombers and
vehicle borne IED is out of
the city before the election
because the Taliban had
threatened immense bloodshed
to disrupt the elections.
This was 2014 was just,
you know,
um,
the first peaceful transition
of power in Afghanistan,
legitimate transfer of power after Karzai.
And so the Taliban wanted
nothing more than to,
to,
to disrupt that process.
They want Sharia law,
they don't want democracy.
And so 2014 ended up being the deadliest
fighting season in Afghanistan's
history,
at least while we were there.
I don't know about the Soviets,
but while we were there
and more civilians,
more tallyman and more coalition forces
were killed in 2014 than any other year.
So yeah.
So I mean,
going into this,
I started to get some,
you know,
jitters here,
they're cold feet,
but you know,
I,
I commit and you know,
I know how to jump,
you know,
like hold your,
hold your balls and junk kind of attitude.
Right.
I know how to do that,
thankfully.
And so that's what you
do is you just jump,
you know,
you just,
you just because I couldn't
live with myself if I didn't.
Right.
I mean,
you couldn't,
I couldn't.
And so it was,
um,
you know,
and really what was really
stressful though was they
started killing journalists
in Afghanistan in 2014.
It's specifically targeting
people that had cameras.
And so,
you know,
every while I was there,
you'd get news reports of,
you know,
two,
two dead journalists are dead
journalists here are two dead there,
you know,
purposely shot by our allies,
our,
our own,
not our allies,
but our,
our own Afghan partners that
we were partnering with,
whether it'd be Afghan national
army and a or Afghan Ello,
Alp Afghan local police would
turn guns on journalists.
And it,
it turns out,
you know,
you never quite understand
why it happened.
A lot of times it's Taliban
infiltrate the ranks of the,
of the,
um,
of the security forces in
Afghanistan that do that.
But,
uh,
but sometimes it's cultural differences.
They don't like cameras pointed at them.
They don't like they're there.
They don't like you to talk to women.
If you talk to women or
open a door for a woman,
you could insult somebody so much that
it's the kind of place where they pull a
gun out and they kill you.
Wow.
Yeah.
So the stress,
the anxiety just never ends because like
on that embed with criminal Graham and
the Cabo police,
you know,
we were a six or seven person
team embedded with a 13,000 men,
Afghan police force.
And so all day long we're surrounding
by Afghans with AK is and RPGs.
And so every building you go into,
you're surrounded by Africans with guns
and there's just six or seven years,
sometimes two or three of you.
And so you're always trying
to put your back to the wall.
And the anxiety of that
is just relentless.
Even though Maine,
nothing may happen,
but just the potential that something's
going to happen is kind of exhausting.
Yeah.
I can only imagine,
especially knowing that some of these
security forces were killing journalists.
Did they give you a list of things?
Never do.
No.
Um,
that's how to learn along the way.
Yeah.
I mean you ask for advice.
I mean,
I think that's one of the weirdest things
about like going to going go into a
place like that is there is no rule book.
All you can look is for
people that have experienced,
that have done it before,
been there before,
and ask and hope somebody takes
you under their wing and you know,
decides to give you a
little bit of comfort,
you know,
and,
and decides to try to teach
you something along the way.
God,
that's gotta be insanely stressful.
So I could just call him,
imagine being a small number of people
also surrounded by all these Afghan
security forces and then also having
the knowledge that some of these people
that Taliban had embedded in some of
these people and they didn't filtrate it
and they were in the ranks and they were,
they were upset that the Americans were
there in the first place and they were
resentful of the whole situation and,
you know,
very angry.
Yeah.
Um,
it was,
you know,
it was mine exhausting my numbing.
It was almost like you,
you don't know where the enemy is.
And it's like,
once you know where the enemy is,
then at least you can focus
on him and you can face him.
But the enemy can be anywhere
in that kind of environment.
And so like it'd be,
you know,
on a patrol or walking through a village
and there's a bunch of guys around and
they all got shovels and you know,
but you know,
some of them are Taliban,
you know that for sure.
Some of them are talent man,
but they're holding a shovel
and you can't prove it.
So you have to really wait until,
you know,
they decided they want to fight that
day because typically it's up to them.
You know,
where they fight,
when they fight,
they're the ones that
determine those things.
That's gotta be really crazy.
So it's very difficult to figure
out who exactly the enemy is.
You looking at one guy,
he might be a farmer and the
guy next to him might be Taliban
or the guy might be a farmer one day
and then he needs money the next,
so he picks up as a k or plants an IED
the next day because he needs money and
he becomes Taliban.
Wow.
Did you learn the language?
No,
I'm a few words here or there.
What do they speak on?
Dari is the people in the north and
Pash tune is the people in the south and
it's really a tribal conflict that
country as opposed to sharia versus Sunni.
So what is the conflict?
It's,
it's very different people.
It's the people in the
north that are dory there,
the Northern Alliance,
they're Asian kind of mixed.
Um,
the,
you know,
used to have those big Buddhist statues
up there and their lands that got blown
up by the Taliban than Islam came into
that country and sort of kick Buddhism
out.
And so it sort of all when Islam,
um,
and then the people in the
south or the past tunes,
you know,
very,
very connected to Iran,
you know,
kind of culturally.
Um,
and so there's a conflict
between those groups.
And then there's also conflicts
with the states around there.
Like India,
Afghanistan really likes the Indian
people and Indian way of life
and the sports,
the music,
Bollywood,
cricket,
you know,
the Indian businessmen all over Kabul,
um,
and Pakistan,
you know,
sort of as at odds with India.
And the last thing they
want is Afghanistan to be
a ally of India to Pakistan
doesn't kind of want surrounded by,
you know,
people they find unfriendly.
So there's,
the conflict is,
you know,
diverse.
It's,
it's,
it's heroin,
it's poppy,
opium.
Um,
a lot of money comes out of that.
And who controls that money
and where does the money go?
Yeah.
And the also the soldiers have to
actually help some of these guys that are
growing poppies because they get
information and because it keeps the,
keeps certain allies in place.
Like they had this thing on Fox News
where Geraldo Rivera was over there and he
was trying to,
uh,
help explain why the soldiers were
guarding poppy fields to people at home.
That was like,
what in the fuck is going on over there?
Well,
here's the good news.
The good news is 90 something
percent of that heroin,
that opium goes to Iran and Russia.
It doesn't come to us.
Ours comes out of Mexico.
It's not good news for
Iran and Russia now,
but as a weapon,
it's good news.
Um,
it meaning that the Taliban used
heroin is a weapon against us.
Like at first when they were in power,
they outlawed the growing of it.
So it went to zero when they
were taken out of power.
Um,
poppy production exploded and huge,
huge growth.
And so everybody grows it.
It's just such a cash crop.
And um,
and so,
but then they tax it,
tell him that makes $200
million a year from,
from some of the analysts had talked to,
from taxing the growing of it and
the movement of it back to Pakistan.
Wow.
That's,
uh,
that's pretty insane.
So that,
is that one of the primary means of,
of generating income for them?
Well yet,
because in Afghanistan there's basically
no roads so they need to grow crops
that ha that don't spoil.
So when they grow,
when they grow up heroin,
when they grow that opium,
then they can store it in bricks and it
doesn't spoil and then they can treat it
like gold or silver.
And so it's not like,
you know,
another kind of food or
other item that spoils.
It's cause they don't have infrastructure
to move stuff to market either.
So it's partly,
those are the reasons partly
to that it's such a big crop.
The must have been an exam,
insane experience and insane
culture shock for you going from,
I mean you were a child star and now
you're a grown man producing documentaries
and then you're in this
insanely odd world.
You traveling around Kabul,
which is essentially the
only city in Afghanistan,
right?
I mean most of Afghanistan is and
run by tribal bore lords,
different SEC segments.
What did,
what is cobble like?
Like,
what does it like to
travel around that city?
It's a very small downtown
center that looks fairly modern,
that has fairly modern looking buildings
that even may have at traffic lights
and sewer.
But once you get out of that sort of
nucleus that may be two or three square
miles of infrastructure.
It just,
because it basically becomes a city of
6 million mud huts and 6 million people,
but all living in mud and dirt roads.
Um,
just a massive,
massive village really.
And then there's Kandahar in the south.
So those are the two,
which is just another massive,
that has no city center.
That's a massive village,
Kandahar,
um,
mud village.
And then,
and then all these valleys around
where there's no roads connecting them.
So people live and die in the same
valleys without going anywhere
in,
they have to get all their
food from that valley.
Yeah.
And what's their primary
source of food there?
They grow it.
They,
they got some of the best
berries I've ever tasted.
I remember we were having,
um,
needing with some Afghan army guys,
planning operation and they brought out
bowls of like berries and they're like
boys and berries and
blackberries and raspberries.
And there were the sweetest,
finest berries I've ever tasted.
They would just taste like sugar.
They were so sweet.
Nothings sour about them.
And so it's a very,
like,
it's very arid place,
but where they have water,
it's very productive land.
They grow amazing fruit orchards,
nuts,
um,
and they have a lot of lambs and sheep.
You typically what they eat for meat.
And so I would think that in
that sort of an environment,
it's very difficult for
progress to take place.
That what progress did we
think of like infrastructure,
sewage systems,
electrical power,
running water,
all that different stuff.
It seems like it's very difficult to,
to change.
I mean,
what,
one of the things that I remember from
the election was when there was a debate
between John Mccain and Obama and
Obama was talking about Afghanistan,
about bringing troops in Afghanistan.
And he was doing it in a way that John
McCain thought was very ignorant of the
environment.
And he said,
you know,
I don't think,
I'm paraphrasing,
but he was saying essentially,
I don't think you know
what it's like over there.
Like that place hasn't changed since
Alexander the great came through.
And when you describe it that way,
I think he kind of puts it in
perspective for people like these people.
It's not going to change.
Like it's one of the reasons why the
Soviets could never win the war there.
It's one of the reasons why it's so
incredibly difficult for anybody to make
any,
well the hope is the Internet.
The hope is the internet because like
literally several dozen TV stations have
sprung up.
Several hundred radio stations have sprung
up in the last years on the Internet
and cell cell signals and cell phones.
You know,
now there is a group of young people that,
and that I've tasted the,
the world through the Internet and they
see a different world and they see the
opportunity,
they see that,
you know,
and,
and those are,
those are the majority of the 8 million
people that came to vote on election
day.
Um,
you know,
and,
and women and young people.
And so the big thing is to try to
give that core group of people in that
country,
the time and the space to grow,
to develop and to get,
you know,
roots of democracy and roots of,
of,
um,
you know,
civil order established,
uh,
to try to deal with the corruption,
the huge amount of corruption
in the Afghan government.
I mean,
this is,
this is a place where fuel trucks
will be coming from Pakistan to say,
fill the downtown.
The police department's fueled
reservoirs in Kabul and on the way,
um,
so much fuel will be stolen
along the way from Pakistan that,
but by the time it gets
to the edges of Kabul,
you know,
all eight trucks will be RPG and burned
because nobody wants evidence that the
trucks were empty.
And so that's the kind of level of
corruption that that is going on that you
know that you have to try
to at the ministerial level,
the ministers like that's where
we've got to make sure we fixed.
I'm,
the other problem with
that country is like,
it's,
it's sustaining itself.
So like you'll go to a outpost and you'll
see vehicles that look fairly well,
like they can be reused for patrols and
they're just sitting there and they'd
been sitting there a long time and
the commander of the army golf say,
what's up with the vehicles?
The guys were like,
we can only do foot patrols.
Well,
what's up with the vehicles?
Why don't you do vehicle patrols?
What?
We don't have a fan belt and we can't
get a fan belt until we bring the vehicle
back to the brigade headquarters 150 miles
away to actually get the fan belt put
on because they won't push the parts
out because of the threat of them being
stolen on the way they,
they want all the equipment to go
back to the brigade headquarters,
which you can't get the vehicle.
There is no tow truck.
So there's those kinds of problems
where they have to figure out how to
logistically resupply their,
their self and sustain themselves.
They have to be trained on all that.
Wow.
That is bananas.
What a crazy place.
Crazy place.
Is there a sense of
helplessness about that?
When,
when you're there,
like when you look at this,
you liked,
how is anybody gonna fix this?
First of all,
Jamie,
can you turn the AC on in here?
It was hot.
It's fucking hat.
Is there a sense of helplessness at all?
Um,
yeah.
You,
you,
I mean it depends on who you talk to.
You talked to the officers in the
army and some of the other folks,
um,
you know,
that see the big picture
sometimes and they're,
um,
they believe it's,
it can,
it can be one,
they believe that the Afghans can win it.
The Afghans can,
can resist the Taliban and then you
talk to the enlisted guys and typically
every one of them says it's going to take
generations and generations to change
this.
And if it changes,
I wouldn't want,
I mean,
how would you possibly get the internet
to these people and these mud huts?
I mean it seems like if
the Internet is the hope,
how do you get the Internet to
people that don't have running water?
I mean it seems like that would be
their number one priority first and,
well,
I mean they're doing a lot of good there.
I mean life.
Um,
you know,
like I was reading some
statistics since we got there.
Like,
you know,
the amount of literacy
has gone through the roof,
you know,
life expectancy,
infant mortality has gone down,
life expectancy has gone up.
So many good things have happened
in 13 years in that place.
We built some roads now and
some infrastructure that
go all the way around the
entire country of Afghanistan
is a giant circle.
And,
and so we've done a lot of good things.
Um,
but basically the international community,
because it wasn't just us,
this was a NATO mission.
The first time I was told
that NATO was ever invoked.
NATO wasn't with,
started to,
uh,
you know,
work in Europe to defend everybody,
uh,
against the,
access,
I guess m and we invoke NATO's support
after September 11th and NATO came to our
aid.
And so that,
what was interesting was,
you know,
there was military members from like 50
or 60 nations in Afghanistan when I was
there.
A lot of them weren't going out and
doing patrols like the Germans were.
And some other countries were
actually out there engaged.
But most of them were sort of,
you know,
doing stuff that was,
um,
nation building kind of events
as opposed to direct combat.
But,
um,
you know,
so that's the hope is that
the international community
doesn't abandoned this
country because if they don't have the
money to pay their army and pay their
soldiers,
it falls apart.
So now the United States has pulling
out the majority of troops from
Afghanistan.
And what happens then?
What is,
what is the,
what's the number one concern from the
people that have been there that are on
the ground?
Like what's the number one concern?
I think America leaving
completely their there.
You know,
the,
the President Asha Afghani and the
Prime Minister of Doula Doula came to
Washington,
I think recently just
talked to the president and
basically both thanked him and
thanked America for all the sacrifice
that it's made to help their country.
But,
but basically basically pleaded with him,
don't leave,
we need you to stay.
We are too fragile.
We are too young.
And I think that's the biggest fear of,
of the people there is that we will
completely abandoned them and Taliban will
come back into power.
Now there's a,
there's a growing segment of,
um,
in this country and all around the world.
I guess that I don't like American,
uh,
interventionalism if that's a word.
They don't like the fact
that we're nation building.
They don't like the fact that we'd go
over there and tried to clean up this mess
that's existed.
I mean,
or you know,
whatever he called a mass,
call it a cultural divide,
what,
whatever you want to call it.
Impose our standards of living
and our ideas in this place.
Um,
but these,
the people that live there,
they want this,
they want to run it.
Yeah.
I mean the locals are so glad.
I mean life under the Taliban was,
was brutal and horrible,
but back to your point of
nation building and stuff,
you know,
either got to commit and do it or you
got to just go do what you gotta do and
leave.
So like,
you know,
when we went into Afghanistan,
right.
And it was to kill al Qaeda and Sama Bin
Ladin and we sort of didn't ever want
to mess with the Taliban.
Really.
Taliban didn't have international goals.
I don't think they were just
wanted their piece of the world.
It was al Qaeda.
That was,
you know,
hurt us,
attacked us,
and Taliban wouldn't give all,
I'll kind of over.
So we went there and tried to,
tried to get kill every,
all kind of member we could
took awhile still happening.
Um,
but the,
the,
you know,
we got drug into this Taliban conflict.
We've got drug into it and 14
years later we're still there.
Um,
so,
you know,
I think there's going to be a debate,
national debate one day on
nation building and using,
you know,
the military to,
to build nations.
Um,
because I always thought the military
was designed to destroy an enemy and,
and then leave.
But now maybe that's
changing and politicians,
you want them to destroy the enemy
or kind of destroy the enemy,
but then help build up a nation.
If that's what you want them to do,
then at least build them like that,
right?
Build them,
um,
to succeed in that environment.
Um,
but I think the fighting season,
the importance of this
is we're going to show,
you know,
how we left Afghanistan with the
fighting season Docu series and whatever
happens in Afghanistan down the road,
if it,
if it crashes and Burns or success story,
you know,
we'll,
we'll be able to reference the fighting
season from the soldiers perspectives of
how we left it in 2014.
There's a lot of people that are very
cynical about nation building because
there's a lot of money involved
and that money involved.
I mean,
especially when Dick Cheney
was the vice president,
of course,
he was the former CEO of Halliburton.
Halliburton got those
gigantic multibillion dollar,
no bid contracts to go over there and
rebuild areas that we had destroyed.
And a lot of people recognize that
there was a whole industry behind that.
Now,
not just the military industrial complex,
but this rebuilding industry,
the contracting.
It was,
it became
an enormous sense,
an enormous source rather of,
of money.
Yeah.
I can't really speak to that too much.
Um,
what I can say is that,
you know,
I saw some,
some places that the Afghans had built
some Afghan bases that they had actually
constructed on their own.
We paid for them to build it.
And you know,
some of the guys that control
the money were telling me,
you know,
this would have taken us
two years and this much,
lots of money to build these guys,
built it in,
you know,
nine months and for way less.
Yeah,
maybe the craftsmanship is not as good.
You know,
it's one of like Mexico kind of block
housing as opposed to what we might have
built.
But it was,
it was enough.
It was official.
It's efficient.
And so,
you know,
these guys I was with with the army,
we're very proud of the fact that they
were able to get money cut loose from
that contracting process and get it to
the Afghans to help their local economy,
to help them build stuff,
you know,
get employed their people.
And so,
you know,
Joe,
I'm sure you know,
you know,
I don't discount what you say at all.
I'm sure that there's,
when there's money involved,
people do crazy things.
Um,
but you know,
I just know the guys that I was with,
they ain't getting paid a lot of money.
The soldiers in getting
paid a lot of money there,
they're walking towards the gunfire,
happy to do it for next to nothing and
not next to nothing that's disrespectful
and they have a sufficient income.
But,
but it's still not to risk your life.
I don't know.
They don't do it for money,
honestly.
They don't do it for month money.
The first day you get up in the morning
in Afghanistan was a feeling like,
like you're in Mars.
It's just like you're in a new unit,
a new world,
you know,
you don't know anybody.
There's no friendly faces,
you know?
Nope.
Everybody's looking at you like,
what are you doing here?
Even the soldiers you're
with are leery of you.
So it's like you're just on your own.
You know?
It's like you taking care of yourself,
self,
self reliance in that place.
Nobody's going to carry your water.
Nobody's going to pack your stuff.
Nobody's gonna make sure you make
it somewhere on time or don't,
you know,
you're just self reliant.
And so it's,
it's just feels like,
okay,
um,
I'm on my own and it's kind of a,
you know,
and then eventually you
know that that wears away.
You start meeting people and you start
seeing friendly faces and there's certain
Afghans that you start to,
to really,
like,
especially the interpreters,
these young men that are in their early
twenties that are risking everything to
work with the US army on the hopes that
they're going to get on the promise that
they're going to get a green
card from the State Department.
And there's many of them
that aren't getting them for,
for whatever reasons,
I don't know.
But these young interpreters
that are risking it all,
I mean,
I remember them saying,
please don't put my face on the picture
because if the Taliban see it and they
can see it now anywhere they said,
then,
you know,
they may kill me.
They may,
one guy said,
they may hang me in my village by
quarters and yell to my family,
come get some meat.
We just slaughtered a sheep.
And so I said,
okay man,
I won't show your face.
But like so,
so,
but anyway,
so you served to meet these,
these young Afghans and you start to
see the commitment they have for their
country,
for what a better way of life.
And it's just so inspiring.
And then show it to me,
make friends with soldiers and you know,
all of a sudden you start to
feel like you're part of the,
of a,
of a group.
So you,
you go out with these people and are what,
what information do they
give you about what's ahead?
Did they say we're leaving,
come with us.
I mean,
how do you know what's going to happen?
Do you,
are you privy to meetings?
Like
yeah,
so there's a process called the
military decision making process.
MDMP and it's when an order comes down
from above that you have a mission,
you sit and you do a big briefing and
you do what's called mission analysis.
And so the leadership of the
battalion in this case task force,
White Devil of the 82nd airborne that
we were embedded with on one of these
missions.
Um,
Lieutenant Colonel Paul Larson,
the commander of task force,
White Devil,
um,
we will call up mission analysis meeting.
And so all of the leadership
of the battalion 800 guys,
but just the,
the leadership would assemble and
you would go through the mission,
you would talk about it.
This is what they want us to accomplish.
This is the resources we,
we think we need.
Um,
now I need,
you know,
all of us to go back
and make a mission plan.
How are we going to move,
you know,
200 guys,
200 miles to the border of Pakistan.
How are we going to set up
shop out there for two weeks?
What villages that were going to air
assault based on intelligence that we can
generate because they only
have finite resources.
So everything has to be,
everything has to be,
all,
all operations are,
are driven by intelligence.
You don't just go somewhere on the hopes
you go there because you have a reason
to go there.
That there's bad guys there,
that there's routes there that they're
moving explosives from Pakistan and
Afghanistan.
And so you do an admission
analysis and then you know,
everybody comes back
together a few days later,
you lay out the plan,
you were fine.
The plan,
you do the location Scout,
I call them location scouts,
like a movie,
like a movie.
Cause I shot him like that.
But you,
you actually go to the potential
forward operating bases,
you're going to strike bases,
you're going to operate from you scout
those you meet with the African partners
that you're going to partner with because
all these operations we want and we're
joint operations Afghans and army next.
And so you meet with them and
then you come back and you,
um,
you run it by the general and you say,
okay,
we've done our homework.
This is what we need.
This is what we're going to accomplish.
These are the risks.
And the general looks at the plan and
either of course as Jemilla's do either,
you know,
it says good no or tweak it and they
usually say tweak it and you tweak it and
then you're off and running.
Then you're conducting the operation.
Now
how did you decide on the amount of days
that you went there and how many hours
of footage did you have to go through
to put together this six part?
It's a six part docu series,
correct?
Yeah.
At six one hours.
It's also on direct TV for any
of you that may have at directv.
The CEO Mike White,
really quick.
Um,
I cold emailed him when I got home from
Afghanistan and he decided to move out
and make this,
but I had 650 hours of footage and um,
and you know,
a lot of it was,
you know,
kind of dead end stories because you
would go out on for a few days with
different soldiers on different
operations and nothing would happen.
And it was just sort of a dead end
opportunity that you couldn't develop.
So
put any of that in there to show
that there's a lot of frustration.
A lot of these things don't pan out.
Not,
no,
we,
we didn't put any dead ends in.
We didn't put any dead in
characters in let's say we,
we,
we put in all the characters that we
wanted to and the missions that we wanted
to show [inaudible] and sometimes
there was conflict in those.
Sometimes,
you know,
between soldiers you'll
see that there's sometimes,
you know,
everyone has this perception
that if you're in the army,
you blindly follow orders.
It's not the case.
You may do that in front of
people blindly follow it.
But behind closed doors,
you,
you don't,
you don't blindly follow anything when
you're dealing with your life and the
life of your teammates.
The stakes are so high.
Everybody wants to go home,
you know,
nobody wants to be the last
person to die in Afghanistan.
So,
so we actually got to see
that whole process of,
you know,
questioning a superior officer,
whether he's doing the right thing or not.
So you got to see they,
they,
they do that in the face
of a superior officer?
Not Typically in face.
Typically behind the scenes they will,
if they have to,
they will if they have to,
if it's in the moment
and they don't have time,
like in the moment if the guy
said go jump off that bridge,
I think he would confront him
face to face cause it's imminent.
Right.
But if it's,
if it's something that you can let slide
for a moment and then go talk to him
later,
that's typically the way they handle it.
Now are you storing tapes?
I mean how many,
how many guys do you have over there
that are filming and how are you getting
this stuff back?
Yeah,
so we're shooting,
um,
I have three camera teams plus me and
so I would embed each camera team with
different units doing different missions.
Then I would rotate through the
camera teams and so we would shoot on,
on,
on cards and we would back every night
and have to backup our media to the hard
drives,
to rugged hard drives.
And then we would,
you know,
have to charge our batteries because we
would run out of batteries oftentimes if
we didn't.
And then we would send that
media back every three,
four weeks,
we'd send a dump of footage back home.
And in my editorial we'd
ingest it and start,
you know,
organizing it,
but 650 hours of footage.
Wow.
So did you have a Internet
access when you're out there?
Like strong inner access?
Never strong satellite.
But if you were like,
you know,
meet a major army base,
like um,
Kandahar and then you would have internet
intermittently but not enough where
you could upload footage
to a server somewhere.
No,
very slow speeds.
Wow.
So you
dealing with hundreds of
hours of footage then,
and you've got to break this down to a
six hour docu series and you have to do
it justice and you have to do it justice
also because not just because it's a
significant part
of American history,
it's the lives of these soldiers that
you have become friends with and comrades
with.
But you're,
you,
you're trying to do this
whole thing justice.
Well.
Yeah,
I mean that's the reason to do it.
I mean,
the reason to do it is to do it justice,
to do it right,
to show the way it is,
to not come at it with
an angular is a spin.
But just to tell their story
and honor how hard they,
what they do is,
and to honor all those who
served there and lost their,
you know,
it's you,
you,
I did it because I wanted
to tell their stories.
You know,
and you don't do that for money.
You don't go get shot at from money.
It just doesn't work that way.
You go to that because you want,
because you feel it's important for the
world to know who we are as a nation,
who are army is and who the
people are behind the army.
The army is an amazing group of guys,
Great Amazing Institution and people and
I thought it was really important too
to show who they are.
They,
they are the best of us.
The best of America I think.
I mean,
they were some of the smartest,
bravest,
courageous people who,
who are doing this because they,
they,
they feel a sense of
love for their country,
true love for their country and,
and the values that we hold deal deer.
And so I wanted to,
to show she showcase that
they have a true love for our
country and true love for the values.
And what do they think they're
accomplishing by being in Afghanistan?
What is the primary sentiment that they
think that they're accomplishing by
being over there?
By eliminating the Taliban,
by weakening the Taliban,
by empowering the local so that they can
help reduce their area of the Taliban.
I don't think they even necessarily
think about some of those things because
they go where the
president tells them to go.
They go where our country
orders them to go.
Um,
I think that's,
it's a,
it's,
it's a more like personal
kind of thing for them.
And that is,
you know,
they,
they're willing to risk it all,
you know,
they're willing to give everything,
um,
to fight the evil of our generation,
radical Islam.
And so,
you know,
they have commitment
like you've never seen,
like I've never seen.
The commitment is phenomenal.
You know,
you think a suicide bombers committed
and have a vehicle borne IED drivers
committed and they are,
but make no doubt about it.
That,
that,
that our soldier that decides to walk
towards the enemy close and destroy him is
every bit as committed as,
as that suicide bomber.
Except we don't go to try to
kill civilians like they do.
Right.
We'd go to try to kill them,
the enemy.
And so I think that's where they,
I think that's the message that I got
from my experience there and watching them
and I think that they're proud of is
that they're willing to do whatever it
takes.
They'll go anywhere you asked them to.
They,
they,
they just,
they will.
I heard soldiers say it as long as
I've got my body armor and my helmet,
I'll go where they have
the hell you want me to.
What do you think is a difference between
the perception the average American
has over here safely guarded,
protected in,
in our country?
What do you think the misconceptions
that most people have are about what's
going on over there?
What are the primary misconceptions?
Um,
that the Africans don't want us there at.
The African people don't want us there.
The Afghans want us there.
The locals want us,
they're the ones that don't want,
um,
you know,
radical Islam and Sharia
law to govern the land.
They want us there.
And so I think that's the thing I
didn't understand when I went there is,
is how much the locals are
grateful and thankful that,
that we are there and that we've,
we've done what we've done.
I mean,
I had Afghan officers in the army,
thank me.
I would say to the camera,
I would point the camera at them and say,
do you have any messages from America?
And they would thank America's parents
for sending sons and daughters here to
die,
for us to,
to fix us,
to help us.
Like they really,
really are thankful that we're there.
And that's just something you
don't get a sense of back here.
Um,
you know,
one of the other things I'm most proud
about the fighting season that I think
you'll get to see is,
um,
you know,
we show how the rules of engagement,
um,
work in ways,
you know,
when,
when it comes to drone warfare,
you know,
there's a perception out there that like
the u s military establishments out of
control,
that they're just sort of
shooting missiles randomly
it bad guys and don't care
about killing civilians.
Well,
I can tell you if you
watched the fighting season,
you'll see something
different to that narrative.
You'll actually see how it works and
when they're willing to and when they're
willing to not risk collateral damage.
The,
the real issue that people have
is when they read just raw,
when they read
the raw numbers of innocent civilians
killed by drones versus the intended
targets,
and they're pretty heavily and on the
side of innocent civilians killed.
I think the last count was something
like 80% that that's hard for people to
swallow.
But here's the thing,
you don't remember,
the army is different than the CIA.
It's different than any
other branch of the military.
That's using drone warfare.
And I think that's an
important distinction that we
have to remember is that the
US army fights according to its own.
It's a,
it's a set of values and principles that
are different from other organizations
that do that stuff.
And I think that's one of the things
about the fighting season is you're going
to see how,
how different they are.
Now we also have this conception of these,
there's perception rather have these
people sitting in a room somewhere with
like an Xbox controller,
no one near the action and they're
controlling these drones and firing.
If these black and white screens looking
at night vision and a very nondescript
images there,
they're trying to determine whether
or not these are the actual enemy.
What is the actual reality
of using those drones?
Well,
I,
I was never with the actual
pilots of the drones.
Where are those pilots?
They can be local or they can
be over here in the states.
I mean they can be,
they can be remote.
Um,
how are they doing it remotely?
Like if they do it remotely as it
through the internet or is it through
satellites
gotta be satellite?
I would,
I don't know.
But I would think it's got to be sound
light and it's instinct control like
there's no delays.
It's instinct control of the,
of the,
of the drone.
But when I
be some delay,
I mean there's a ping,
there must be something.
But the reality is the guys I was,
I worked with,
I was with task force white
devil when we were using drones.
Um,
so our guys would be watching the drone
feeds and you would be looking on,
you know,
the enemy to see if you
could pick up an RPG,
um,
or a weapon that's a prestige weapons
system because it has to be sort of a,
a higher level weapon system to
make them a valid military target,
let's say.
So you would be looking at,
at the drone feeds and then the guys
would be typing and communicating with the
drum pilots in a chat room.
And so there's real time communication
going on and real time coordination and
realtime jags involved.
John a judge advocate general's I'm
involved in the process at this point of,
you know,
have you met the rules of engagement
because there's different kinds of strikes
to there's kinetic strikes,
dynamic strikes.
So like if you're in,
um,
uh,
troops in combat situation and you're
the ground force commander and you're
running a company and you know that
there's an enemy fighting position by that
rock,
you know,
theoretically you have the authority if
there's no other assets available to get
the drone to attack the enemy behind
the rock as the ground force commander.
But then there's other,
other,
um,
kinds of strikes that are like preplanned,
like you're going after a terrorist
that has a known name and a known face.
And so the rules of engagement for him
will be different than the rules of
engagement for the troops in
combat rules of engagement.
So there's all these different,
and depending on where
you're on and the list,
how bad they want you is how much
risk they're willing to take as far as
collateral damage.
Was there ever a time when you were
over there where you second guessed your
decision?
No,
I,
I never,
I mean I,
okay,
one moment we just been
in a troops and conduct,
we just had like an hour fight with
four different enemy fighting positions,
about 800 meters north of us.
And so we'd had about an hour
gunfight from 800 meters.
But the bullets when they zip overhead,
they sound like they're
breaking the sound barrier.
And so there's like a sonic boom and you
could see them playing in the dust all
around you.
And so,
you know,
all that's going on for an hour.
And then we,
we dropped B,
one bomber flew overhead and we dropped,
you couldn't see it but it dropped 500
pound bombs on the enemy and the firing
stopped and you know,
after about a half hour and
the ground force commander,
Captain Ray Adams said,
let's go do a battle damage assessment.
Let's walk over there.
Let's see,
you know,
if there's any left.
And so at that moment,
like when,
you know,
the platoon is strapping up to walk across
800 meters of open valley desert into
this green zone,
which is really thick vegetation where
they can hide anywhere and there's mud
walls everywhere.
You know,
I'm starting to think
to myself at this point,
like I have a great wife.
I really liked to Panga.
I like my,
I like my wife.
I like my kids,
you know,
I'm walking with this young platoon,
to this place where we
were just in a fight.
I said,
why am I doing it?
And I questioned why am I
doing it and should I go?
And then I thought,
oh yeah,
I should go,
but why?
And then I realized I was going because
they were going and I had to tell people
they were going.
So I went with them.
Wow.
And so you get over there.
And what was the damage assessment?
Just pieces of clothing.
Uh,
you know,
remanence of people.
Um,
no,
you know,
a couple guys hiding that we,
that we found,
um,
had shovels in their hands.
They put down their weapons.
So there was nothing you could do.
And um,
as far as like,
you couldn't prove anything.
So I'll remember that.
I remember this one,
you know,
big,
Big Army Guy,
I'll letting them and these
guys came up to him and after,
you know,
cat madams question them,
the Afghan army guys questioned,
everybody knew that
they were 99.9% Taliban.
You know,
they,
they said that they didn't hear any guns,
didn't hear any bullets.
So you know what he talking about?
The earth just shook from miles.
Um,
and we had a look and go and uh,
as we let them go,
they,
they went up to try to shake my
hand and I'm holding a camera.
I couldn't shake their hand,
tried to shake other people's hands.
Some people shook their hands goodbye
and they went up to this big sergeant and
tried to shake his hand and he just said,
you know,
get the fuck Outta here motherfucker.
I'll get you next time.
And he was so pissed that
we had to let them go.
Those guys that just tried to kill his,
his buddies,
him.
And it's only because they
didn't have their guns on them.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's so weird.
What a weird,
weird war.
The Afghans look at us most and they must
shake their heads sometimes because I
mean,
I know,
I mean I,
I think I know what would have happened
if we weren't there of camera's weren't
there.
If the army wasn't there,
they,
those guys would have
never walked out of there.
There was a time World War II when the
United States had taken a lot of Nazi
prisoners and had them in prisoner of war
camps in America and treated them very
well and it was a chest before they had
found out how badly Americans were being
treated over in Germany.
And there was all these
different stories of American,
more prisoners being gunned down,
firing squads.
They would find their frozen bodies tied
and bound and there was a big public
outcry,
congressional hearings,
and they were trying to figure
out why are we doing this?
This is a tough time for America.
Why are we treating these
Nazi prisoners so well?
And they're not
reciprocating like what it,
what do we do about this?
And,
um,
they decided to keep doing what's right
and keep treating the prisoners under
the same standards of
the Geneva Convention.
And it's those,
those regulations when things are horrific
like that where it seems like where
people are like,
well,
why would you do that?
Why would you let them go to those?
Those might be the only thing that keep
a situation like war from breaking down
and becoming even more
horrible than it actually is.
Agree.
I mean,
I agree.
It sounds counter intuitive,
right?
I agree.
I mean,
if you don't have those standards,
then you know,
then start,
we'll start cutting their heads off,
I guess.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
We'll start making youtube videos.
So,
but we luckily have those
standards and you know,
we're not them.
And that was,
that was one of the main concerns about
Guantanamo Bay that we weren't following
the Geneva Convention,
that we had said that we would,
uh,
we wouldn't do it for al Qaeda,
that I'll kind of,
prisoners would not be treated
under the Geneva Convention.
And the big concern would be what would
happen if they catch our troops over
there?
What would they do to them
to know the answer to that?
Exactly.
That was the whole idea of the
Geneva Convention the first place.
So even though like what you
saw seems counterintuitive.
I mean
it's Kinda how you have to do it well.
Yeah.
And the soldiers were frustrated and then
of course they follow orders and they
let him go and they just hope next time,
like he said,
I'll get you next time,
motherfucker.
They just hope next time you hold his gun
a little longer so that you can verify
with either a drone or with your own
eyes that he was an enemy combatant.
Wow.
Is there a time that stands out that was
the most brutal or particularly brutal
of all the different and
firefights are different,
different scenarios that you encountered?
You know,
it was a time,
it was a firefight that
I wasn't there for.
One of my camera guys was,
was there and river was his name.
And uh,
he's from Oregon.
He's a biker and a crazy
guy covered in tattoos.
And missing his front tooth,
total hillbilly love river and um,
and so river was in a gunfight with this
young platoon and we were reviewing his
footage and I saw a tracer go by him,
like between us that far away
and I just really got Kinda,
it's so comb the reality
that river almost got shot.
And then there was another time when I
had to get permission to descend bed.
One of my cameramen from the U s army,
Jake,
uh,
camera guy from Australia that I hired
who lives there and I had a decent bed,
him from the u s army because he was
going on a mission with the Afghans.
When you say he lives there,
do you mean he lives in Afghanistan,
Kabul.
Whoa.
He's a war is a war journalist.
She lives there all year round now he's
moving to places where he can cover
isis.
He's an interesting guy.
And so and so Jake had it in bed with
the Afghans and I had to go meet with the
general to get permission to get him in
bed with the Afghans because there was
no US forces on the
ground where he was going.
And it was a place
called the Tangy valley,
very dangerous valley.
The side of the law,
single largest loss of life of
US service members at 38 died in,
I shouldn't look a,
that was shot down by RPG in that valley.
And it was a really important mission
because the Tango Valley is just outside
Kabul,
but it's a Taliban stronghold.
So they can,
they can plan their operations and
attack cool very quickly from the tiny
valley.
And so he was important
that we told this story.
And so I went to talk with
general towns in and he said,
okay,
so you know,
are you prepared to see your camera guy?
Um,
you know,
in an orange jumpsuit on his knees,
on the Internet because the
place you're putting in,
that's the kind of thing that happens
and nobody is going to go get him.
No,
no US allies or us,
we'll go get him.
And I said,
I haven't said yes.
And that was like probably the hardest
moment cause I had to make a conscious
conscious decision.
Right then just say yes.
Did you express this to him?
Yeah,
I mean Jake,
Jake knows Jake.
Jake knew Jake's Jake.
Did you tell him that?
That was the sentence that was
the way it was described to you?
Yeah,
I did.
What did he say?
No problem.
Ricky and his cheerful
Australian attitude.
No problem.
Wiki fucking Australians are crazy,
crazy,
crazy.
He's a bull.
This guy,
he's a boy.
Wow.
It sounds like a nutty dude.
What it,
what motivates that guy?
Jay Gum was in the Australian army
and I think he was involved with some,
some event that was really
traumatizing involving,
you know,
some kids getting hurt and killed.
And so it was somewhere in Indonesia
where the Australians were,
I think.
And so he ever since has been
involved ever since that event.
And they left the army.
Um,
he's been trying to tell the story of
how war affects kids and so he's got a
special focus on kids.
And so that's,
that's what motivates Jake I think.
And he does this three 65.
He's over there all the time.
All the time.
Does he learn yearn for a normal life?
No,
he actually learns for the next gunfight.
He yearns for the next to gunfight.
He,
he's one of those guys,
the chases gunfights around the world.
So he's covering isis right now.
He's in with those dudes.
The Christian militia is out there
that are fighting isis right now.
Wow.
That is intense man.
So how many,
how many reporters or how many a
cameraman rather do you have over there?
There was,
um,
four plus me on j could only stay with
us for about six weeks and had to leave.
And then,
uh,
one of my camera guys was
getting sick all the time.
I mean,
really bad,
sick,
dehydrated.
Um,
and so he couldn't leave the fobs,
so he would cover sort of as
a fob forward operating bases.
And so he would cover like the drone story
for me because that's in a controlled
environment.
And so we would,
the other three we go out into the field
with various platoons and stuff and
operations and then he would stay back.
Was there anybody that you got
close to over there that you lost?
No,
I didn't.
None of our guys,
um,
were killed.
So we killed Taliban.
We didn't have any arg.
Our guys killed their wife
while we were with them.
Uh,
fortunately was that the first
time you'd see the human body?
Um,
fully from act of war I'm
in PR in the real flesh.
Yah,
for sure.
What was that like was like
the first time you saw it was,
it's kind of gross is definitely gross.
There's nothing pretty about it.
It's,
it's Har,
it's actually its absolute heart.
You can tell people died,
violent deaths,
pieces,
missing chunks,
like ugly.
Then you had seen all this
I'm sure on the Internet.
Yeah.
And now the difference between seeing
on the Internet and being there live,
we're all comes home and you realize
this is what they're trying to do.
To the people that are around you.
Yeah.
What did that feel like?
It's not personal I guess
is what I would say.
You know,
it's,
it's not like they want to kill Joe.
They want to kill Ricky.
They want to kill what we represent,
they want to kill what we live,
what we are,
what we live for,
the values we hold dear.
And so because of religious fanaticism,
because,
because I think according to an army,
until officer I spoke with I thought
was very knowledgeable because in order
for,
for their,
um,
prophecies to come true,
they have to start world war
three and then their profit,
we'll come back and you know,
bring peace in order to the world.
But he won't come back until they
are able to trigger a big event,
a massive event to start world war three.
And so that's,
that's the hardcore,
hottest motivation.
There's a,
there's a distinction there between the
hardcore jihadist and the average person
who's a Muslim.
And this is what gets sort of turned
around and churned around rather and
debated back and forth in America when
people start using the term Islamophobia
because there are people that
practice Islam that a very polite,
peaceful people that don't want
any harm to occur to anybody,
and then there are radical people that
are out of their fucking mind and want to
shoot people for drawing cartoons.
Yeah,
the radicals.
I mean even in Afghanistan,
they'll pay a kid 25 bucks,
20 bucks to go plant an IED.
The kids not doing it necessarily because
he wants necessarily to fight Jihad.
He wants $20 he wants a pair of Levi's.
He Wa he doesn't wear Levi's probably,
but he wants something and he needs
money for it and so that kids,
not hardcore Jada,
he needs money,
but he dies like anybody else.
When you,
when you,
when you step over that line,
it's incredible that the only way to
really get someone to do something like
that is religion.
It's really the only way.
It's the only way to get
someone to blow themselves up.
It's the only way to get someone
to sacrifice their own lives.
You have to give them this idea in their
head that something better waits for
them after they do it.
And you have to have them really,
really believe it.
And there's only one way.
It's gotta be religion.
There's nothing else you don't know.
One blows themselves up,
her Ferrari's.
You don't blow yourself up
for diamonds because he can't.
You can't.
It doesn't work that way.
Well,
think about that.
You sex,
they use
promise of virgins.
And that's a powerful
basic urge of men sex.
And so they must somehow use
that in a twisted way to,
to play on boys,
teenage boys going through puberty,
and they convinced them that they're
going to have all the sex you want.
My Gosh.
And you believe it.
Well,
it's also,
you're talking about people with limited
education and they're very young.
Those,
those two factors together and culturally,
the entire areas,
Muslim.
So it's not like the idea of not being
Islamic is almost more foreign than the
idea of being a suicide bomber.
Oh yeah.
Especially when some of the suicide
bombers or a mortars and revered with
posters of them and tributes to them,
you know,
and
there was a school in Pakistan and a,
there was a documentary on it or they
were a training these young kids to become
suicide bombers.
And they had this sign
on the wall that it,
first of all,
they showed all these images.
They had these enshrined images of the
children that had blown themselves up.
And they had this,
uh,
this sign on the wall that said,
today's students are
tomorrow's holy martyrs.
And,
and they were explaining,
you know,
like what that meant and what
it means to fight against the,
the enemy.
And it was,
it was just so hard to watch.
So hard to look at these young kids that
were being indoctrinated into this way
of thinking and knowing
that this is a washed isn't,
well,
you can't fix that.
You can't go over there now and,
and fix those teachers,
tell them they shouldn't be doing this,
fixed the religious leaders to
straighten the mindsets of the people,
adjust their perceptions.
You're not going to be able to do it.
Like you're,
you have a,
an area of the world that's almost
inexorably sick and it just,
it is what it is and now we
have to deal with it globally.
You have to deal with the consequences
of those people getting older and going
out in the world and affecting people
with the ideology that's been sort of
embedded into their brain.
It's,
that's popping up though worldwide Joe.
That ideology is popping up in Canada
and the US and Europe all through France.
Look at Charlie Hebdo.
Yeah.
So it's like a cancer and
that is spreading and it
can grow anywhere from any
mosque,
from any teacher and it's
going to take a global,
global the whole world to fix it.
I don't know how else,
you know,
we do it except,
except it's a,
oh it's a world effort to,
to sort of show these people a new way
and it's got to come from within them.
It's got to come from within them.
Is there resistance in Afghanistan
to religious fundamentalism?
Are there people that are against
like actively and vocally against Al
and against the Taliban?
Uh,
yeah.
I mean there's,
yeah,
there's millions of people there that
don't want Taliban rule and they're active
and vocal about about it.
There are,
and there's a whole
initiative where we're,
you know,
I think it's,
I forget the movement,
but it's like the anti Taliban
movement and it's literally,
you know,
villages in remote places past June.
Wally is,
um,
one of their laws,
you know,
but I think it's stems from that kind of
culture where they're actively against
the Taliban and resisting
and fighting and you know,
trying to,
trying to try to create
a new way for themselves.
But it's a crazy place.
I mean,
it's a crazy place.
Here's a story.
So this guy was telling me he was an
African and he was talking to me about how
he knew of a story where one African
man get killed another and the one who
survived.
We went to the family of
the one he killed and said,
I asked for your mercy,
forgiveness and protection.
And so passion Wally means
they have to do that.
It means we got to take you,
take you in,
protect you,
feed you,
how's you,
it's part of this cultural thing.
And so they took him in and you know,
took him the man that killed
their son and or father.
And he lived with them many years,
you know,
10 years,
12 years,
whatever.
It was.
Long time.
And then he decided he was
going to go home one day and I,
you know,
I spent a decade there.
They must have forgiven me.
They loved me by now.
And as soon as he walks through the door,
they killed him.
And why?
As soon as you walk through the door,
they killed him.
So as soon as he left,
as soon as you said he was leaving,
yeah,
because,
because then their obligation was,
was fulfilled.
That's insane.
So this guy had been with them for
over a decade under their protection.
They were feeding him.
Yeah,
because of this law.
Right.
And this is,
what is it called again?
Posh asked June Wally.
And what does that mean?
I don't exactly know,
but I believe it means that we will
protect and take care of you if you ask.
Wow.
So,
so they did it until he left
and then they killed him.
That that's absurd.
That's only,
again,
that would only take place in a
situation where religion was involved,
I would think.
And then there's other stuff,
man.
It's just like Chai boys dancing boys.
Yeah.
What's that about?
It's,
it's a,
it's a status symbol to have a boy and,
and use them for sexual reasons.
A status symbol.
Yeah.
You're a powerful man.
If you have a boy.
How old are these boys?
Young?
Six.
Eight,
14.
How common is this?
It's pretty common if,
I mean there's not that many chiefs,
but if you're achieve
like a warlord.
Yeah.
Or even even less than that.
Successful businessman.
So,
whoa.
That's what I said.
There's this weird
stuff goes on there and,
but this is not something
that is prohibited.
This is prohibited in Islam.
I didn't dive into it.
I didn't even want to research it.
Homosexuality has prohibited.
I need more.
I'm looking into it.
I just heard about it and I heard soldiers
talking about it and people that had
seen it and yeah,
I mean drinking's prohibited.
Other things are prohibitive but you know,
they,
I think they do them.
Wow.
So how,
how is this defined?
Like when you're,
you're around these people and you see
these guys with these six year old kids,
like how do you know that it's not as son?
How do you know which I was never in
the presence of that cause I never saw
that.
I never saw that.
So it's not that common.
I don't know what percentage it is,
but I don't think it's like,
you know,
I I'm going to guess 5% 10% that's a lot.
Maybe I'm guessing,
I'm guessing.
Okay.
Right,
right.
Wow.
Yeah.
Cause I had heard that from guys who
would want over there and perform for the
troops that,
you know,
they'd seen a lot of homosexuality
like and a lot of the sexual abuse
women are for breeding boys or for
pleasure is what statement that they say
sometimes.
Some guys,
some Afghans and women
are treated terribly,
terribly,
terribly.
They're horribly under the Taliban,
horribly stoned to death.
I mean,
but even though I don't under the Taliban,
there was a,
uh,
a woman beaten to death in Kabul a few
months back because the leader in the
church,
whatever the church he was going to,
uh,
um,
said that she burned a cron.
And in fact he was like
an argument they had.
He and her were,
she didn't like him charging.
She had mentally handicapped woman.
She didn't like him charging for
trinkets that he was selling to people.
And so he said,
you know,
you burned a cross on to
people and they killed her.
So women are not treated well there.
When you got home,
when you did the hundred plus days
there and go home and came back to your
beautiful family and your beautiful
house and Southern California,
what was that like?
Oh my gosh.
Um,
it was confusing,
really confusing at first,
uh,
months.
It took a month to just feel normal.
But I was so glad when
I got off the plane.
I almost kits the dirty gutter in lax
because of all the problems we have here.
It is such an amazing place
when you from a place like that.
And so that was the
initial feeling and then,
and then,
uh,
it was sort of trying to just sort of,
um,
care again about the,
the normal things in life,
you know,
caring about whatever it is,
bills,
um,
your,
your kids have issues or concerns that
you have to learn to find important again
because the things that you
just experienced where like,
well that's not so bad.
Okay.
So,
okay,
you just lost all your money.
That's not so bad.
Okay.
You know,
you just,
um,
okay,
you just failed that you just got
in a car accident that's not so bad.
Your boyfriend just dumped you.
What are you complaining about?
Your bank accounts at zero,
what are you complaining about?
Like that was all that learning,
relearning to care again about
other people's frivolous things,
but the big picture.
But to those people,
they're not frivolous cause they don't,
haven't had just to that experience
you had the lack of perspective.
Yeah.
I mean,
the more intense the situation or
the more intense experiences are,
the more those other
experiences seems so doll,
which is why spoiled people that
don't have anything go wrong.
I mean,
that's why they'll,
they will get freaked out about
something so minor and trivial.
Yeah.
Other victim of their own ignorance and,
and success or trust fund,
whatever you call it.
But the reason why I bring this
up is because in a lot of ways,
that was you.
I mean,
you were a young my
ass off for everything.
You certainly did.
That's never me.
I didn't grow up with a
silver spoon in my mouth.
But you read of this show
called silver spoons,
but I worked right,
but you were rich was a floor plan.
You were a little kid with
eating off a plastic spoons.
Right.
But you know what I'm saying?
A celebrity and a TV star.
I mean,
you were a huge star when you get there.
You know what it takes,
it takes an,
a massive amount of hard work and
dedication and perseverance to get there.
Nobody's given it.
So this perception that you know,
somehow we live,
we were privileged.
C'Mon,
we worked our asses off.
I worked my ass off since
I was five years old.
Right?
But what am I saying is
you develop that way.
I mean,
you were famous.
I saw you in the champ
and I was a little kid.
My Dad took me to see the champion.
I remember crying when you were
crying over John Voight's dead body.
By the way,
that fucking story that you told me
about them being mean to you right before
that to get you to cry.
That is one of the most fucked
up Hollywood actor stories.
Did anybody ever told me talking
about my dead grandmother?
Yeah,
I'm can get you emotionally
invested in that scene.
I mean,
it worked.
It really worked.
I mean,
it was incredible.
I remember leaving that movie
theater fucking crying the Holy Shit.
But my point being is you,
you lived a life of privilege.
You know a lot of ways.
Okay.
If you say so when it was a
little defensive here for that,
your
privilege,
when it's privileged or earned privilege,
you earned where five earned.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Earn world before Sorta,
okay,
you did your work,
but I mean you're working in acting.
Acting is not that hard.
Do you think it's that hard
being not a normal kids?
Hard.
That's hard.
Going not to school's hard
and not being on on softball,
little league teams,
hard,
all sorts of things were hard,
but definitely unusual but not Kabul.
Hard knock.
Cobble hard.
Yeah.
Not Cobble hard.
So going from that to this and
it at this stage of your life,
the current stage of your life
with all your life experiences,
it boiling down to this,
this docu series that
you're putting together,
which is probably the most
intense thing you've ever done.
Yeah.
I mean,
what a perspective enhancer that's got
to be to go from being a famous child
with this view of the world
and then as a grown man with a family
to be over there in Afghanistan embedded
for a hundred days,
experiencing firefights
on a daily basis almost.
It was a great experience,
Joe.
And it changed me forever.
It changed,
it changed me forever in many great ways.
I don't,
I don't see any negative that has
come out of it for me honestly.
Um,
except maybe wanting to do it again,
you know,
and you want to do it again.
I mean that's,
that's the risk is has it sort
of lit a fire in me to like,
well you did a fantastic
job by all accounts on this
docu-series I read reviews
of it.
People love it and they,
they,
they say this is really
intense and really,
um,
what was the word that I'd read?
But uh,
comprehensive I think was the
way they were describing it.
Like you,
you got deep into this.
This isn't something you can
cover in a 90 minute documentary,
which is why you decided to
stretch it out over six hours.
Yeah,
I mean we look at it from the ending
of America's longest war from various
perspectives.
It's epic in scope,
but we get deep inside those,
those perspectives,
you know,
um,
and
know I just,
I don't know what the future brings for
me right now because that's honestly the
thing I'm most confused about
is like how do I go back to,
um,
you know,
certain career choices
that I perhaps once was,
you know,
really excited about and
wanting to achieve and goals
enacting maybe in acting,
even in films,
in TV and even in production,
even producing,
you know,
even writing,
whatever it may be.
Like,
you know,
I got to figure out again,
I got to figure out what,
what's next for me cause
I have no fricking clue.
No clue.
Just because this experience
was so intense and so
powerful that it just sort of
reshaped who as a person.
Absolutely.
Well I'm talking to from the time you
returned mean I could tell that it was
you.
You had,
there was almost like a rekindling
of a spark inside of you.
Like you,
you had this new sort of new feeling of
importance of what you were working on.
That was a very,
very intense,
absolutely.
I mean I really felt,
you know,
that I was making a difference as
opposed to just creating entertainment.
Yeah.
I really felt like I
was making a difference,
like,
like educating people
about the art of war,
how battles are fought,
the military science behind it.
Like,
because that's what I found interesting
is how do you take an op order and
operational order and then develop it
and then execute it and then how do you
overwhelm and destroy the enemy when you,
when you finally find him,
how do you overwhelm and destroy the
enemy and choreograph the Cynthia
destruction in the moment?
How do you call in the air weapons teams,
the Apaches,
how do you call him the B
ones and the fast moving jets,
how'd he call him?
The artillery,
how do you call all that and coordinate
all that in the moment so that you can
destroy the enemy as fast as possible.
That's what I wanted to see.
C and I and I found it and I,
I'm going to show it to everybody.
Do you think from here you'll continue
to do documentaries exploring the
military or will you start doing
other things that interested?
Because what it seems to me
as your friend is that you,
you just have to have
something that excites you,
something that interests you and
then you just fucking dive in.
Man,
you go whole hog now.
That's what you do.
So it is,
it's the only way I've
ever known how to do it.
As far as anything I've ever
made is at worth anything.
As far as,
you know,
any value has been something that I really
was excited about doing and wanted to
do and was passionate about.
And so I,
I don't know what's next for me.
I mean,
I love dogs and maybe
I'll do something on dogs,
you know,
and smile a little more,
for while.
Yeah,
I love dogs.
And they're great dogs are gray dog.
Two of them.
I might need a break.
Yeah.
I'm going to Alaska,
um,
at the end of June going floating
on a river and fishing with my,
my son's and my nephews.
That should be fun.
12 days.
So that's kind of my break
I'm really stoked about.
And then I'll come back in July and 4th
of July in Alaska by the way is off the
hook.
Yeah.
You can get all the fireworks,
all the big kinds you
want and just go nuts.
So that's what we're going to do.
And,
and then I'll hopefully figure it out,
you know,
but I know,
I know I got to take
my family into account.
You know what they want because you know,
I got a family.
Yeah.
Um,
well you also have the freedom
to make those decisions.
You know,
you have the freedom to decide
what you want to do and then really
direct yourself towards whatever your
passions are.
Is there anything that you're
interested in at the level that you were
interested in?
This military thing?
Cause I think the military thing,
you had always had an interest for it,
but it was really sort of sparked by the
series that you had done for the army
that would,
that really just,
it's really my grandfather,
it's sparked it like he was a captain
in the army World War II and he took six
what called deuce and
a half flat bed trucks,
big trucks with each one had two
50 calibers mounted on the backs.
And so,
um,
he took six of those as close infantry
support all the way through France to
Germany,
to the Rhine River.
And I think I was the only
person he ever told stories too.
But I remember sitting
at the feet of his chair,
like as a kid growing up and he
gave me all this memorabilia,
gave me the dagger that he took off a
dead Nazi mayor gave me his rifle that he,
he carried,
you know,
gave me the things that is being at the
things that he found treasures to him he
gave me.
And so I think sitting at his feet,
you know,
sort of is what I'm
planted,
that seed,
you know,
of,
of the military.
And I remember,
you know,
he would tell me about the green
berets and the rangers and,
and you know how they would paint their
face black and they could move in the
night and nobody could see them and they
could just kill an enemy very quickly
with their hands.
Um,
and he would tell me,
stare stories about them.
Germans stretching
piano wire across roads.
And so as you come down in a willys
jeep and everybody's decapitated,
they put it right at
the height of your head.
And so,
you know,
he told me about stories of coming
across those places and you know,
and then he,
and then we started mitigating it by,
by,
by putting a steel rod at the front of
the jeep to snap the wire before it,
before he hit it.
And so he would tell me all these
stories about what he went through.
And I think that's really
where my interest came.
And to answer your question,
I don't know if I'm as
passionate about anything,
you know,
besides my kids,
my wife,
and,
and um,
you know,
us the u s the u s and what we,
and the army that,
that defends it.
What's also got to be really hard once
you experience something that is as
intense as being embedded in combat in
any crazy war like what's going on in
Afghanistan,
it's gotta be very difficult to find
something that's going to ignite the spark
to that extent.
Yeah.
I'm,
and that's one of the
things I'm concerned about,
you know,
really I am,
I'm like,
what is next for me?
What do I care about enough to
do what I did this last time?
Uh,
don't know.
So you just might be a
war documentary guy now.
I,
I don't know if my wife
can take that honestly.
So I don't know.
I don't know what's going to,
yeah,
and you kind of have to be over there.
It's not like you just
send people over there,
film it,
and then come back and edit it.
I can't because as far as right now,
like it was my,
it was,
it was my working with those units,
those platoons and those leaders
in the squads being there,
that made all the difference because,
because I,
I think they understood,
they understood my,
uh,
they could feel while I was there.
And if it wasn't,
if it's not the right camera guys,
if it's not the right people
in bed with those units,
they'll shut them down.
If they feel like you're doing
something that will be critical of them.
Or are you paying them an unjust light?
Yeah.
If you're looking for dirt,
right.
A lot of them must be,
they will shut you down.
How many embedded reporters
that they have over there?
Not like,
not like we did none.
I mean we were the only
team that was like this.
They had people come from
newspapers for three days,
two days,
five days,
you know,
go to one place,
and,
but no,
this was a massive,
the army putting massive amount of effort
into embedding five of us for three
months,
you know?
And ultimately they'll just see,
you know,
like the ground force commander
at those units at the unit level,
if,
if they don't want you there,
there's nobody,
no general that said you can come to
Afghanistan is going to call up a ground
force commander and say
you will take these guys,
you will show them.
It doesn't work like that
because ultimately the ground
force commander has his
authority.
He's the guy right there that's going to,
you know that that's a keep you alive,
that has to protect you,
that's to interact with you.
And if he doesn't want you,
you're gone.
So it's really tough to,
to,
you know,
to think about how I could produce this
without me actually at least going there
to open the doors and to embed people.
Right.
But then when you went over
there the first time to Scout,
how many days did you go
over there for three weeks?
Three weeks for the first time.
First Time.
And
did you come back from that three
weeks with any apprehension?
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
I came back because I didn't have any,
you know,
I had to write a big check and I
had to put my money where mouth was.
And so I had to get John
Paul to write a check.
And so you know,
you invest your friend's money.
That's tension.
Now that apprehension about that Ma,
you know,
I never asked a friend to
invest money in a project.
I've always only invest in my own.
And so why'd you decide
to ask someone else?
Because my wife kept telling me,
Ricky,
you need partners.
You need people to work with,
cause I'm kind of on my own a lot,
you know,
as far as,
um,
and so she's like,
you need to collaborate with people.
You need to work together with people.
So I asked my friend John
Paul and she got pissed.
Why you asking our friend for money?
I'm like,
well honey,
he's wanting me to work with people,
collaborate with people,
jump Paul's my friend
and he gets the content.
He's a big boy.
He can risk the money.
He's worth billions.
And she's like,
yeah,
but you've changed the dynamic
between us and our friends.
And I'm like,
honey,
it's going to be fine.
I didn't know if was gonna be fine.
But it was a great feeling
when I came home and I,
I wrote a check to him,
I'll tell you that and paid him back.
But I had apprehension about money.
I had apprehension about,
you know,
all those things you think about like
I had to buy life insurance for all my
camera man.
I had to buy death and dismemberment,
insurance,
disability insurance,
you know,
I had to make sure that their
wives were okay with them going,
you know,
and,
and their moms and their dads because
some of the guys were young camera guys
are not married.
And so,
you know,
taking on all that responsibility.
So I had lots of,
lots of,
um,
lots of reasons to back
out all along the process,
but just pushed,
pushed,
pushed.
Did you edit the entire thing yourself?
Me and a three story teams and my partner,
Jim,
retired,
Colonel Raven.
And so what we,
what we did was we had three major
in beds and we put a camera team,
I,
sorry,
a story,
an editor,
Tina story producer and an
editing editor on each team.
So each team only had to learn,
say 200 hours of footage.
They didn't have to learn
all 600 hours of footage.
And so then each story producing team
and editor would work with Jim and I and
we would craft the episodes.
And so I,
I got,
um,
I sent,
I came back from July,
2014 from Afghanistan.
I tried to sell this to a
different production companies,
different networks throughout
the entire summer and fall,
couldn't make a deal with any of them
because they really didn't want me to end
up producing it.
They wanted to bring other people to
take it over and just sort of acquire the
footage.
And so turned down some things that
could have worked out for different deals
and then went into February and had no,
like,
what am I gonna do with this?
Like,
I got a lot of money invested in
this and I've got a lot of hopes,
you know,
I told the Army I was going to get it out,
what am I going to do?
So I emailed Mike White's Yoel,
directv cold and him
a link to the trailer.
And then within 18 hours I had
a handshake deal and you know,
and that was in,
um,
February,
middle,
February.
And I had 12 weeks or 11 weeks to edit
six one hour episodes from all that
footage and hadn't even started.
Wow.
That's not ideal.
Right?
It's not ideal.
What would you rather,
about how much time would you rather have?
Uh,
uh,
maybe,
maybe 16 weeks instead of 11.
Have you ever considered doing maybe
a director's cut if this is really
successful,
would you,
I mean,
you have so much footage,
it almost seems like you
could do another six hours.
Well,
I never thought about it,
but you're right.
We could,
we could do other things.
There's so much that
we had to leave behind.
There's so much story there.
Um,
I mean,
I can only imagine.
We'll see.
Um,
it's going well.
People are liking it.
Some of soldiers,
Joe on Facebook and sent
me messages and said like,
thank you for making this because now
my wife and my family understand what I
went through in Afghanistan or thank you,
my son was in,
in your series.
Thank you for showing us part of his life,
you know,
really,
really nice messages in.
And to be honest with that was my goal
the whole time was to make something that
the soldiers would look at and say,
if you want to understand Afghanistan,
then watch the fighting season because
it's the closest you'll get to war
without going.
There's nothing closer.
I can't wait to watch it.
If there's anything else you need to say.
Um,
is there anything else you want to
tell people about this experience?
Yeah,
yeah.
You know what?
We don't
army strong.
The guys I was with were strong,
motivated,
you know,
after 14 years of war.
Now
we have some really experienced leaders
that have been deployed multiple times
and been,
it had been in this fight multiple times.
And so that generation of experience
is teaching the next generation.
And,
um,
you know,
I just want people to understand that,
a military may be having our
army maybe having budget issues.
I hear about in the paper,
I may have other,
other issues,
but one thing,
they don't have a problem
with his leadership.
The people that lead these young
soldiers are like dedicated,
trained,
experienced leaders.
And their goal is to take
everyone else gets home.
Like seriously,
they're goal is to everything they do
to mitigate risk as much as possible.
So they keep those kids
home and you can see it.
That's why they train them.
That's why they're hard on them so hard.
They want to take them all home.
And so I just want to leave
it with our army strong.
You know,
it's,
it's strong and it's
experienced and it's um,
it's a privilege to have told their
story and a thank you to all of the vets,
whoever served and thank you to those
families that let them serve because it's
a life commitment.
It's not like a job.
It's like the whole family's involved.
And where would we,
where would we be without them?
I mean,
honestly,
where would we be without them?
We'd have a draft.
We'd have,
we'd have a draft.
I mean,
think about it Joe.
We have a volunteer army that
has been at war for 14 years.
All volunteers.
I heard,
I think chairman joint chief of staff,
Keith Mo not Mullane,
one of the chairman said,
uh,
you know,
an all volunteer army was never
designed to be at war of 14 years.
That's why you have conscripts and drafts
and we don't need it because we have
that many young people that are willing
to go out there and do this and answer
that call and show up.
And I think that's just amazing.
And this is the perfect day
to do this on Memorial Day.
So thanks for coming in here.
And uh,
thank you everybody that's served.
Thank you everybody that's serving.
Thank you everybody that's listening,
watching this and thank you everybody
that has watched the fighting season or
we'll watch it.
It is available right now.
You can get it on iTunes.
A Ricky is on,
he's on Twitter and he needs
more Twitter followers.
So go to Ricky Schroder,
r on Twitter,
your Facebook page with the Facebook page.
Ricky Schroeder.
Do you have a fighting season website?
We have a fighting season,
um,
youtube channel and finding
season Facebook channel.
And so people can watch clips from that.
Oh,
you can go to youtube and
you'll see all sorts of clips,
all sorts of clips,
and go out and buy a
folks support this cause.
This was,
uh,
an amazing project and,
I'm going to buy it.
I'm buying it tonight.
I'm gonna Watch it tonight and I'm just,
thanks man.
Thanks.
Thanks for everything.
Thanks for,
thanks for what you do please.
My,
what?
I do as easy as fuck.
All right.
That's it folks.
That's the end of this again,
Ricky Schroder on Twitter and
find him on Facebook and a,
the fighting season is available
right now on iTunes and Amazon when,
uh,
tomorrow,
and Amazon.
So a go get it folks.
All right.
Much love.
Bye.
Yeah.